dr zemla sen decided to test scp-914  with two identical wooden cross pendants  each measuring three inches in length  the first cross was run through the  machinery on rough it produced one  fragment of wood with the same mass  which was cut flat on three sides this  was hypothesized to be a portion of a  much larger cross the second cross run  through the clockwork on the setting  fine produced a wooden crucifix carved  with an ornate depiction of jesus christ  dr sen proposed that these results  indicate scp-914 understands religion dr  piras suggested that these results imply  as cp 914 understands the use of the  objects put into it and their meaning on  a cultural level